I haven't been saying almost anything about
political endorsements this cycle and people
who have [inaudible]
but watching or listening to the show for
a while probably can guess why, which is that
I do not believe that political endorsements
really matter, at least not the vast majority
of them and particularly not this far into
a democratic primary where there have been
so many debates it's been going on for so
long.
Most people are so familiar with the candidates,
uh, and even those who are not, are not particularly
going to be making decisions on the basis
of one endorsement or another in a way that
could move the needle.
And I've said before that that's really the
key thing.
The needle doesn't get moved that much by
endorsements.
Endorsements are the type of thing that endorsements
from media outlets generate more media about
the endorsements, but they don't really move
the needle very much.
That being said, they can be interesting to
look at because they do tell us some interesting
things about what the establishment might
be thinking or what legacy corporate media
things.
Or we might look at reactions to endorsements,
which can sometimes tell us something interesting
about a race, and that's the case with the
New York times endorsements that were made
yesterday after a whole bunch of fanfare and
pomp and circumstance and releasing of little
video excerpts of the interviews that the
New York times did with each of the different
democratic candidates.
The New York times opinion page has issued
its endorsement and they have broken with
convention, they've decided to endorse two
candidates.
Now importantly, I saw tweets saying they
endorsed a ticket in endorsing two candidates.
They did not.
The New York times says that they are endorsing
two separate candidates, not a ticket that
should run together, and those candidates
are Amy Klobuchar and Elizabeth Warren.
The New York times points out that they spent
a whole bunch of time with the candidates
that this is a key choice for Democrats who
wanted to feed Trump and so on and so forth.
Giving context for why this is the way they
decided to do it.
And their conclusion is that the most effective
candidates for each of the two approaches
that they say Democrats could choose are Elizabeth
Warren and Amy Klobuchar.
So the two approaches you can probably guess
are a more progressive approach where they're
saying it's Warren, not Bernie, that Democrats
should go with.
And a more centrist establishment approach
where they're saying it is Klobuchar not Joe
Biden or Pete Buddha judge that they should
go with.
These are my words in terms of calling them
the progressive and the centrist as I interpret
what the New York times writes, they use other
phrasiology.
There's a paragraph also about Bernie Sanders
being 79 at an inauguration time.
They mentioned that he had a heart attack
and they also write that Bernie's lack of
compromising and over promising is a reason
why the progressive choice should not be Bernie.
It should be Warren.
If Democrats say that's the way they want
to go, they say, quote, Mr. Sanders would
be 79 when he assumed office and after an
October heart attack, his health is a serious
concern.
Then there's how Mr. Sanders approaches politics.
He boasts that compromise is anathema to him.
Only his prescriptions can be the right ones.
Even though most are overly rigid, untested,
and divisive.
He promises that once in office, a ground
swell of support will emerge to push through
his agenda.
Three years into the Trump administration,
we see little advantage to exchanging one
over promising divisive figure in Washington
for another good news.
Then they say that Elizabeth Warren has emerged
as a standard bearer for the democratic left
and the New York times goes on to list a bunch
of different reasons why they say Warren is
the way to go for the progressive choice rather
than Bernie as a they.
They.
Those are, first of all, she is a gifted storyteller
in terms of how the system is rigged.
Now notice that each, a lot of these pros
are thinly veiled digs at Bernie, so when
they say she's a gifted storyteller about
how the system is rigged, which feels less
bombastic than other ideas.
That's a reference to Bernie.
Bernie is using other language and is applying
bombast which they are being implicitly critical
of.
They say they like that Elizabeth Warren is
committed to reform rather than tearing down
and rebuilding it, which is more of the burning
approach.
Very early on I did a story about even if
on policy they are similar on many issues.
Bernie and Warren have some real differences.
One of those differences is the approach,
the idea of Elizabeth Warren reforming the
things not working about the system.
Bernie tearing down the system and rebuilding
it all together.
When you read between the lines, this bullet
point about how Warren is committed to reform
is a thinly veiled or maybe not so thinly
veiled critique of Bernie Sanders.
They say campaign policy plans are serious.
When it comes to Elizabeth Warren, it seems
to be an implication that maybe they see Bernie's
campaign plans is not so serious.
They also say Elizabeth Warren should be the
progressive choice for the democratic party
because she will increase federal investment
in clean energy research.
She'll wean us off of fossil fuels.
She will expand universal childcare, free
public college and social security.
So then there is why Klobuchar for the moderate
centrists and the New York times points out
that if you want to go with a more establishment
candidate, a more centrist candidate, that
even though Biden is winning the polls, it's
only because of familiarity more than anything
else and that Biden's age is a sign that he
should be passing the torch and they say that
it is Amy Klobuchar who should have the torch
passed to her.
They say quote good news then that Amy Klobuchar
has emerged as a standard bearer for the democratic
center.
Her vision goes beyond the incremental, given
the polarization in Washington and beyond,
the best chance to enact many progressive
plans could be under a Klobuchar administration.
They go on to explain the Senator from Minnesota
is the very definition of Midwestern charisma,
grit and stick to witness.
Her lengthy tenure in the Senate and bipartisan
credentials would make her a deal maker, a
real one, and uniter for the wings of the
party and perhaps the nation, you know, in
looking at the reaction to Amy Klobuchar during
the debates and looking at how the progressive
left reacts to her, I don't know that she
would actually be a uniter of the wings of
the party.
But again, this is the New York times assessment
of this.
What they are effectively saying is she's
slightly more progressive than Biden.
She's younger, and from a practical perspective,
she might get more done.
So this is the endorsement of the New York
times two options, progressive or centrist,
if you want to go progressive, the New York
times says, take Warren if you want to go
centrist.
The New York times says, take Amy Klobuchar.
So here's the deal.
I don't think the New York times has any responsibility
to choose people they think will win.
So as an example, Amy Klobuchar has no shot.
She's continuing to pull 3% nationally, sees
she's in fifth place, place in Iowa, and likely
will get zero delegates there.
She's in fifth place in New Hampshire and
is not going to get any delegates there.
She's in seventh place in Nevada, in South
Carolina.
Amy Klobuchar is pulling worse than people
who are no longer even in the race.
Cory Booker in South Carolina, he's out of
the race.
He's pulling better than Amy Klobuchar, so
I don't think that that matters when it comes
to who they endorse, endorse whoever they
think is best based on whatever metrics they're
applying, not who they think they will win.
So they endorsed Klobuchar.
If Dems want to go centrist and Warren, if
Dems want to go progressive, the real problem
I have is that they seem to be ignoring the
actual records of candidates in their assessments.
So when they say if the democratic party wants
to go left, go with Warren over Bernie.
They frame Bernie as a simply my way or the
highway type of guy.
When in reality, Bernie Sanders has had many
successes negotiating with Republicans in
the Senate.
The New York times has even written articles
about Bernie successes negotiating with Republicans
in the Senate.
Amy Klobuchar on the other hand is not really
a more progressive version of Joe Biden in
any real practical sense.
Look at her record voting for Trump's horrible
extremist judges recently.
Uh, which again the New York times has also
covered as has the daily beast.
Uh, and we are showing you an article talking
about that.
So the real issue for me is, you know, endorse
whoever you want that they, it's their endorsement,
right?
It's not mine.
We can disagree about the strategy behind
it, but the problem is that they are using
incorrect assertions.
They are basing their endorsements on facts
that are not really facts.
And what I believe that they did is they decided
who they were going to endorse first and they
worked backwards to justify it.
They decided we want to endorse Warren over
Bernie, so let's find a way of justifying
it.
And they said, well, Warren's more pragmatic.
Bernie is a my way or the highway guy, Bernie
will be 79.
When an inauguration comes.
They backed their way in a, it's like a post
facto rationalization to get to where it is.
They decided initially they wanted to get,
let's endorse Klobuchar over Biden.
We can say Biden's age and that is time has
passed, but we'll ignore a whole bunch of
stuff about Klobuchar and we'll be able to
justify the endorsements we want to make anyway,
and if you watch the videos, I know that these
are only excerpts, but go and watch the videos
when they are actually interviewing the different
candidates and look at their demeanor to the
candidates that they ended up not endorsing.
Watch the interview with Bernie Sanders and
honestly tell me that they seem to actually
open to endorsing Bernie Sanders.
That's not what I saw when I watched it.
This is not anything other than saying I believe
that these endorsements were decided upon.
Maybe not explicitly, they might not have
said it, but they knew where they wanted to
go with them and they built a case around
that.
More like a defense attorney or a prosecutor,
rather than simply being a juror and saying,
let's look at all the facts and then come
to our conclusion.
In the end, I still don't think this matters,
but I want to hear from you about it.
What do you think, uh, is the goal of the
New York times endorsements, particularly
when Amy Clovis Klobuchar has no chance of
winning?
Uh, do you think it is posturing of some kind?
Do you think it is more meant to just muddle
things up in a, in a way that will end up
being pro establishment?
Whatever you think about the endorsements,
I want to hear from you.
If you're watching on YouTube, leave a comment
replying to this video.
If you're not, send me a tweet on Twitter
at D Pacman.
While you're there, follow the show on Twitter
as well.
At David Pakman show, we've got a lot to discuss
on the first day of Donald Trump's Senate
impeachment trial